oh hi everyone my name is James welcome
to be presenting to fester today all
personal treatment enriched and options
for mice and rats so most people in the
laboratory animal science feel and
familiar with the push is in the
industry for the youth environmental
richer for laboratory animals and this
can be seen just by the increase in the
number of publications in the area for
about 35 publications in 9th ed so in
two thousand publication NIR 2015 couple
I'll committed ego we have been
examinating just a few different types
of the richness in different rocks and
strains of mice and rats which is what
I'm presenting today so there's been
getting benefits regarding the use
environmentally and richness visit
published including d three handle
stress and mortgage setting rules so the
purpose of environmental position is
today is natural habitat as possible to
laboratory animals without compromising
the research with compounding compounds
variable so we need to be crying animal
resources necessary to facilitate
species disappear finessing and bikes as
well as to mingle breath so for our
birthday evaluated the safety and use of
a novel or cotton fiber pad and we have
the vehicle Dominus in inbred and out
red lights and rap so we included
educators result as well as inventory
pages which are just the cages that we
maintain for commercial sale so our main
outcome of interest was next score and
we used a previously published flooring
system by pets and others and just
quickly as it assistance based on one's
request for ease wisdom where one is
where the animals have their native and
touch you
it was put into the cage always to apply
which is a complete dome of an ass
Buddhism small hole in the top four
interested so every hue he also reported
the number of cups or letters of I
weight of the process leading percentage
Pauline behavior morbidity or power
these lawsuits appearance in the
inventory agents we afforded the net for
the eighth year mortgage and mortality
quietly into disappearance so there were
no different position control in its
rich groups for any soccer trade in
regards to behavior morbidity while
halle share their disappearance another
data is chef on the concern though for
study to it was more of a qualitative
study in the first study we've been
tracked pei through the 13-week study
which is production efficiency index
which is a measure of reproductive
company we also recorded any embarrass
minding will educate ruinous behavior
morbidity mortality as well as a
enrichment utilization so in this study
we've seen them the use of diamonds
which is sort of a rolled up towel
echovox which is more like a filter
paper and there are novel cotton fighter
pada Zaman met at fortis Saudis in North
America it didn't stop the train right
breast and so overall there were no
inherent results regarding behavior
morbidity mortality in any of your study
and all of our mouse models utilize the
diamond that's enrichment although some
use it more than others and I'm some
next better than other strengths we also
found with the diamond sources highly
utilized by our wraps around norwayne in
the front Dalek studies such as each
represented today will enable us to
determine s practices for enrichment a
wagon Tory Brodus to the overarching
goal of making sure annuals are cared
for properly and you know to propose a
three
as well by refining our methods to
produce more reliance gives us at it so
that we can totally reduces the number
of animals use and our research thank
you